happy new year and welcome to a
new edition of las vegas now in
spanish your digital connection to the world of
entertainment here in las vegas
cheers to natalia bad luck the arrival of
the great mexican artist also
known as la luna de america is
coming to  las vegas' ana gabriel will bring her
world tour for love you guys are here to
attend and this coming february 12 at
mgm grand garden vida you can still
get tickets for that magical night
via ticketmaster.com
now we will talk about eighties rock
and the cheap trick band who bring  for the
second time his musical residence at
scratch the first show of this
legendary band is on February 25 to
buy your tickets and more information
visit scratch dotcom
speaking of residences there are several
reports of the complete cancellation of
the residence of david books the
vocalist of  the iconic band mangel
in apparently the reason behind this is the
concern about the cases due to the
coronavirus is impo  It is important to emphasize that
this information has not been confirmed
by the artist or his representatives,
but if you visit the house
of blues website where this singer would perform,
all his shows are marked as
canceled as more details come out, we
will keep you informed, we
continue talking about the shows in
striptease that lights up and announced new
schedules and special scene packages
to enjoy their
colorful performances in the starter to find your
tickets or more information just
visit track dotcom
if you are looking for what to do this
weekend you can enjoy a
full live show  of eighties hits at the
red road resort where the
manex spas cover band will perform this
Friday starting at 9 pm this is an
event for people over 21 years of age
and remember it is completely free
let's do a spin on topics and talk  of
the lunar new year parade in downtown
san martin this will be held on
tuesday first  February starting
at six in the afternoon there you can
enjoy various performances such as
traditional dances and much more this
event will take place in the central park and it
is completely free
good for movie lovers the short
film society
of am and announced its
contenders  for its annual festival that
event normally takes place in
boulder city but due to the pandemic it will
be held virtually
from February 10 to 14 visit
am surf selection point org to buy
your tickets and much more
good until  Your edition of Las
Vegas in Spanish has arrived. Don't forget to
visit Isla or Dotcom if you need more
information about these events.
Thank you very much for your attention. See
you next week. Greetings from Natalia Mar.
Sound
[Music]